okay so John carbon is the thing is one
of my favorite films ever made the movie
is the gold standard for practical
effects and on top of this the film has
an extremely well crafted story that
still stands the test of time lace with
paranoia the movie is meant to leave us
constantly second guessing which
characters are the thing and this
extends to the ending itself the movie
closes out with Charles and McCready
warming themselves by the blazes of
their base before the coal Creeps in and
finally kills them for decades people
have questioned whether child's is a
thing or not and for the first part of
the video I want to discuss why I think
that he was now this is something I've
gone back and forth over throughout the
decades and initially I believe that
Charles is one of the good guys however
there are two very important things that
come at the end and I think this spells
it out their child is indeed an alien
now the first of these comes when we
catch him watching over the base from
the sidelines Charles is instructed to
keep an eye out and he stands in one of
the rooms that leads to the outside
later on we see that he's abandoned his
post and we get a look at the room which
now has the door wide open now you might
not notice this but the coats are on
completely different hangers to what
they were originally on when we first
saw Charles in the room placing these
shots beside each other we can see
they're all laid out in a completely
different way in the movie we discovered
that the thing rips through your clothes
in order to kill you and my theory is
that the creature Ambush child's at this
point and then there was a struggle this
caused some of the codes to fall off the
pegs and then in a hurry the thing grab
one to wear and then put the others up
so it didn't look like they'd been an
attack child's code in the scene is navy
blue and when he comes to meet McCready
at the end it appears to be a creamy
white color now this may be due to the
snow and there has been several people
that have argued the code is blue we
just can't see it either way I think the
peg position is a lot more telling and
these codes have been rearranged to
spell it out to us what's going on now
though this may be a continuity out it's
important to bear in mind that the
things production schedule was delayed
heavily this was due to weather
conditions and it gave carbon a month on
end to plan out my new details and this
is why the script is so tight we see
Childs go out into the snow and the
lights cut out just a couple of seconds
later hitting at him sabotaging it and
then heading out into the snow now
McCready meeting Childs I think also
spells out exactly what's going on with
the pair in the scene McCready gives
child a drink and he then smirks after
the character takes a swig of it I think
this is very telling and the more I
watch it the more I think this is
actually a test this is because in the
movie We're told that the inhabitants of
the camp should prepare their own meals
this is clearly spelling out that they
shouldn't share food a drink because the
thing acts like a virus and it could
spread through this there was a
follow-up sequel script that was
unfortunately scrapped but it described
the thing in more detail and it said it
would create a perfect imitation of
someone now what I mean by this is if
they had a blood clot it would have one
too and if they had a cold it would even
take over the cells of the virus and
imitate that as well Giles would no
doubt be warned about sharing food in
liquids however he takes a drink without
questioning it McCready then smirks as
if he's got him because he knows the
thing wouldn't care about this if Childs
is already a thing then he wouldn't mind
sharing drinks because he's already been
infected drinks are also away could pass
on its cells and take over someone else
so it would willingly drink this because
it would give it an end to take over
McCready just as he takes a drink the
theme tune also kicks in hinting to us
through the score about what McCready
has just realized might be a reach but
yeah look
now the theme tune itself plays
perfectly upon the sense of isolation as
we have a single note playing over and
over again rather than a full orchestral
theme even the note in the score is
alone and it's something that really
elevates the soundtrack
now there's also the fact that child
doesn't have a visible breath and
there's no light in his eyes on the 4K
Blu-ray there's a commentary with Dean
cunni who explains there's a way to
figure out who's human and who isn't he
said you'll notice there's always an eye
light we call it a little gleam in the
eye of the actor it gives light if this
light is missing then it means that the
character is a thing and it is absent in
the spinal scene however Carpenter said
this was only the case in the blood test
scene so it wouldn't really matter
either way for the ending honestly I
don't think we'll ever get a clear
answer over whether Charles is a thing
or not because knowing is not the point
of the film we are meant to be
constantly second guessing this and it's
a reason why the movie is still talked
about 40 years later it's laced with a
constant feeling of not knowing what's
really going on and this is seen from
the opening all the way to the end
confusion and paranoia is what makes the
movie so great and it's in almost every
aspect of the film we're not meant to
know why the Norwegians are chasing the
dog and the fact they don't speak
English is put in to throw us off over
what's really going on however if you do
speak Norwegian and spoiler alert
because this guy gives away the whole
film the character says get the hell
away from that thing that's not a dog
it's some sort of thing it's imitating a
dog it isn't real get away you idiot now
the fact that the thing disguises itself
as a dog is also a genius move for the
story dogs are of course man's best
friend and this unassuming husky is
instantly brought into the group because
it's seen as a victim it's also allowed
to lick people without question and pass
on its germs potentially transmaking a
thing into others because it's an animal
it's also given unrestricted access to
the entire compound so the alien can
just walk around until it's eventually
put in the kennel a really cool moment
happens when we see duck stitching of
bennings and in the background we can
catch Clark and the dog he's bandaging
up the dog but this ends up not being on
it later because the thing has an
accelerated healing Factor now we're
gonna get into the rest of the movie in
just a bit but if you're enjoying the
video then do the right thing and hit
that Thumbs Up Button also make sure you
subscribe to get assimilated into the
rest of the channel and I hope you enjoy
the rest of the video now one of the
biggest mysteries in the movie in
retrospect is who got to the blood Gary
was said to be the only one who had the
keys with Docking Windows occasionally
getting access to this both are revealed
to be human during the blood test so who
got into the cabinet doesn't really make
sense how about there's a split second
audio cue that lets us know when the
keys could have been snatched listen
closely at this
a huge illustrator of Asia for pointing
this out and if you listen closely you
can hear the keys dropping
it's possible that they were snatched
during the confusion and this would give
the thing access to the blood it's a
great detail and what I'll love about
the movie is how well crafted things are
on the intro to show us what the
characters are really like we catch
McCready playing chess against the
computer and it pulls off an impossible
move to win McCready then tips his drink
into the machine to break it and this is
very much foreshadowing the entire plot
of the film the computer very much
represents the alien which cheats and
manipulates the game so that it can win
on the other side of this McCready is
willing to burn it all down just to come
out on top the computer is now
and had the alien not come in then I
don't know what you would have done for
the next couple of months because you
wouldn't be playing any more chess now
Gary also breaks through a window in
order to shoot the Norwegian this is
quite cowardly and it shows that though
he's the leader he will hang back and
try and keep out of trouble he does this
later on when he hands over the
leadership position we also have
bennings who rushes in and gets shot and
though he's not actually the first
person to become a thing he is the first
one we learn about the Norwegian also
has weird goggles on with tiny eye
sockets making him seem impossible to
connect with because we can't see his
eyes this heightens the sense of
paranoia because he's someone we know
nothing about who's brandishing a gun
and screaming in a foreign language now
who gets turned first we don't know but
we do see a silhouette on the wall with
curly hair this could either be Norris
or Palmer and to be completely honest
with you when not meant to know who it
is Carpenter actually casts a completely
different person for this Shadow who
just so happen to have very curly hair
because of this we don't know which
character it is and it heightens the
paranoia I love the way the intro plays
out slowly introducing us to the
characters and Carpenter even has a bit
of fun with the music cues as we see the
dog making its way through the base over
the top of this we can hear Superstition
by Stevie Wonder
[Music]
I only really noticed when doing an
in-depth breakdown on the film because
it feels like the kind of song you'd
hear on a radio randomly playing in the
background uh some of the group fracture
off and there's a team that traveled to
the Norwegian base which is when the dog
thing makes its first move it purposely
Waits until people are divided which is
a tactic that we see throughout the film
now upon reaching the base they find a
cube-like structure that has been broken
out of from the inside subliminally this
is meant to be a similar shape to your
coffin and the idea that summing is
burst out of it is supposed to leave us
with a feeling of dread idea is that
it's a monster a vampire or something
unknown or hinted to us here when
crafting the film Carpenter also made a
rule that the thing doesn't really have
a form it never appears the same way
twice either and therefore we never
really get a true grasp of what it
really is however amongst its body we
also see something familiar something we
recognize but this is twisted and
malformed into something horrific after
collecting the carcass from the base the
thing that makes its best attack through
using the dog one of the reasons I think
that Norris was probably assimilated
first is that we see Palmer with child
and later on he's cleared his being the
Creature if it was the thing to me it
would have attacked at this point and
therefore I think we can rule out Palmer
now if we look at the color on the
silhouette too it's also similar to
jumper and under shirt that we see
Norris wearing throughout either way the
dog attack is horrifying and it shows
how useless the guns are against the
Beast instead they have to burn it with
fire because the majority of our weapons
just don't work this is carried out by
Charles alongside McCready they're the
only characters that actually managed to
kill a thing interestingly they're the
only two characters that survive until
the end but when the child says oh look
we're being over it and Shout outsomak
pamlic on Reddit for pointing out that
this scene actually foreshadows to death
in events of the film one dog is shot
similar to Clark and others are absorbed
and some are burnt interestingly two
dogs escape and this represents how
McCready and Charles both get away right
maybe it's not a thing then anyway the
next day Blair examines the creature and
it's possible that he gets infected at
this point we see him touching the
carcass with a pencil and then he puts
it to his lips which would be enough for
it to potentially infect him Blair then
goes crazy and smashes Up the Radio Room
along with all the transports out of the
base I have seen lots of theories saying
that this is potentially applied by the
thing to have Blair removed so it can
work on the ship we find at the end
however I think he's probably
assimilated later for a number of
reasons firstly we find him studying the
creature on his computer alone this runs
through a simulation of how the thing
duplicates itself if player was a thing
he would need to know this and to me he
definitely would want to pass it on now
when they visit his cabin later we also
see that he has a noose hanging up which
he set up to end his own life this is
likely in the case that the thing came
to get him and therefore I think he was
absorbed much later either way bled puts
the idea mccready's head that he needs
to watch Clark which ultimately leads to
McCready shooting him he was never a
thing but this scene creates a domino
effect that leads to an actual person's
death the blood bank sabotage is
discovered and a little detail on dark
is that he has a nose ring the thing
can't replicate an organic materials and
this is something we discover in the
2011 film so yeah you'd need a time
machine to know this but it's a nice
little detail when we revisit the movie
now another detail I absolutely love
happens right after this when Windows
goes to grab the shotgun the group chase
after him too but you might notice that
some members are absent this is norrison
Palmer who hang back and we later see
them wetting down the corridor all the
people in this shot are human and it
shows that they've turned on each other
whilst the actual things hang back and
let it all play out another nice touch
here is that the sniper's weapon from
the start actually appears in the
cabinet where the other Firearms are
kept the incident at McCready Shack
happens and we get the amazing chess
scene this was accomplished using an
actual amputee with a mask and it stands
as one of the best practical effects in
cinema interestingly Palmer self
snitches during this moment and points
out Norris's head boys wondered what
this was for and it's possible that the
individual styles of the thing are so
centered on their own Survival that
they'll happily kill others in order to
gain trust it's even possible that
things don't know their things and that
the cells inside actually hide out and
wait until it's the perfect time to
strike Coulda the blood test scene and
in a nice bit of set dressing you see a
poster behind McCready of someone
showing ID this says they aren't labeled
Chum and this is a nice little nod to
how the thing isn't labeled chump see a
chump now I love the body language in
the scene too and as each character is
tested we see them looking intently at
McCready this is in the case of every
single character who's transfixed by the
character carrying out the test well
every character except one Palmer just
stares down at the floor whilst his test
is being carried out because he already
knows the result he even smirks as if to
say well this is it and that the
explosion he puts his plan into place
although Windows is taken out I love the
sense of relief that extends to this
part in which the rest of the cast are
all cleared there's a real sense of
alleviation knowing we can trust certain
characters again this shows just how
much paranoia that the movie induces
typically in horror movies humans and
the quote-unquote group are the people
that we feel at ease with for example in
slasher movies the times that are the
least tense are when the characters are
all together because we know there's
safety in numbers it's only when they
split up that we feel uneasy but the
thing is a reverse of that even when the
characters are in a group there's still
that feeling of attention because we
don't know who to trust then go to
Blair's cabin and discover the shape
that he's building underneath it slowly
he picks them off one by one and in
interesting detail here is that Blair
doesn't wear a coat this is because the
thing doesn't actually mind the
temperature and it was just wearing
coats in order to blend in now once
Blair's defeated we end with Charles and
McCready potentially sharing a drink
either as friends or enemies good game
my guy which closes out the film also
also Windows was called that because
he's always wearing sunglasses and
that's our breakdown and I hope you
enjoyed the trip through one of the best
films ever made I think the thing will
probably still be discussed in another
40 years and who knows what will be
found the more that people watch through
it obviously if we missed anything then
make sure you comment below as I'd love
to hear your thoughts on the film if you
want to be able to watch we have a
breakdown of all the cool details in
Jordan peels to know which will be
linked on screen right now now the way
thank you for singing through this I've
been Paul I'll see you next time take
care peace